you're absolutely right I mean if you
look at just to give you a few a few
markers if you look at the number of
women on boards of directors of the
fortune 500 companies i think it's like
fourteen percent something something
like that if you look at the number of
fortune 500 companies that have more
than three women on the executive
committee it's I think it's a hundred
companies have more than three women and
so in general if you look at that
businesses like investment banking or
finance women are very much
underrepresented there and if you look
across most business schools and I think
the average across all business schools
is under thirty percent women our school
happens to be unusual and that we have
and have for a long time add the largest
percentage of women in in our MBA
programs or over forty percent and but
it's certainly true that bit in business
as a whole you women are
underrepresented whereas in medicine and
law and other professions there they're
increasingly increasingly evident and if
you look at women if you look at women's
success in school at every level of
education the average performance of
women is better than the average
performance of men but what's also true
is that the variability of men's
performance is greater so I think of
that as the you know more genius nerds
and frat boys as opposed to study
performers of phenomenon but what that
means is that by the time you get to
graduation it's close to sixty percent
women who are graduating from
from university colleges and
universities so women are dominant there
but not in the world of business so
there's a big puzzle I believe that some
of it some of it is biology that women
take time out to bear children and that
that interferes with the with the career
track I also believe that some of it is
that I believe that some of it
represents unexploited opportunity for
the world of business we have these
incredibly talented well-educated part
of our population who are going into
other professions but not into business
there's something something wrong this
it seems to me that there's money being
left on the table and and it maybe being
left there because we don't find the
right ways to to assimilate women but
i'm also a big believer that you know
there are lots of books written about
how women need to change to be able to
compete in the world of men and i
actually think that that that's kind of
backwards that really men need to change
and the world of business needs to
change to be more accommodating to women
well I think that I think it's probably
true that a lot of businesses don't are
not well adapted to the needs of to the
particular needs of women but I also
think it's true that a lot of men don't
understand how to they don't understand
women in the workplace and what their
needs and and what just what their
different social characteristics are so
rather than needing women who behave
more like men I think we need men who
understand that women don't behave the
same as as men necessarily in the
workplace one of the things that that it
turns out is that a lot of women who
take time out of the workforce to bear
children and possibly to raise them for
a while don't necessarily want to go
back into that world they want to go
back into a world where they have more
independence and and control so you know
a successful woman who's had a career in
Wall Street been on the trading desk
then been successful by all the norms
that Wall Street applies takes time out
and then realizes me you know maybe
there's more to life than than just this
so that's part of the issue I mean I are
there things that that we can do I don't
exactly know but I think that finding
pathways finding ways for women to
transition back into the workforce after
taking time out is one of the things
that a lot of companies are doing I
think that would help a lot another
issue is just sheer numbers i mean i
think that that when women have strong
networks of support that it makes a
difference i think numbers makes a big
difference and it tends to change the
character of the workplace but how we
get from where we are now to their i
don't know the answer to that we're
trying we're producing lots of lots of
well-trained brilliant young mba women